TRUMP.RC LARGELY BERN
NOWO DISCUSS IS
TEXAR DA
>> IT'S A SL
>> LET'S START WITH THE FA F S.
YOU HAVE RELIED ON THE
CEN
TANGIBLE WUR
LIFE AND THOSE OF YOURAS SOMEON
WO
THAT THERE W AENY
SIFIED INFORMATIONN ANTION A
WE KE BOWA
CITOE
M T ONE TO WITHHOLD
ITICISM AND EVENWNSIDE MADI
TRUTH.LL BU ,
WHY WHAT IT JUSTIFY WHAT THRTME
ALLY BOILS DOWITUESTIOTHS ASL FT
AONCR
EVIDENCE THAT TRUMWACATION.VEN'Y
GIVE THEK.M SE ISSUEA WHILE NOW?
I E SENGH BACKLASH FM
REPUBLICANS.
YOU'RE SEEING EROALESCE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT SID
THE ISSUE THEY'RE ON WITH TRUMP.
SEEN A LOT COALESCE AROUNDIS ON
ODEMOCRATS.HERE DOES BENGTORYFT
AND I THINK PEOPLE ARE RIRATED
THINK THERE
ARE ARY CLINTON FOLKS O AR THIN
FBI.ELY.
IT JT
T I' R
DNON'DE  SAY, IT DID G, THE FB
DIREORD OFF ON APPOINTED BY TRUA
THE DOCUMENTS THAT HAD BEEN
ESLEEDTHER OR NOT
ABOUT LAT AND S UT ORMEIS
LAW ENFORCEMENPROVENPROVEN GUIL?
>> THID
MEASURE. WE'RE GOING AFTER A
WGAIN,
YONNPOLITICAL.
PEHE PO
YOU CAN'T.
AND IT DOESNM TOE Y AS A THAT.
AIN, WHYOT JUST AS
>> DID
OUE NEGOTIATIN
AND TRYING TO GETHE
INFORMATIOFROM HIM.
>> HE DI
E DIDN'T TURN OVER
BOXES. >> I THI HSAYING, WHATEV
ENVIRONMENT.
THIT.THE ONLY REASON WES BECAUSP
NOD NK WE WOULD HAVE FIGURED
IT OUT EVEN IF HHADN'T.
AWYERS SIGNE
DOCUMENT THEY HAVE NOTHING LEFT.
I NEFARIOUS, WH
NOT Y,, WE DON'T BELVE
LET OM AND LET'S GO THESBOXEN.T.
F US DONALD
TRUMIS
AT BEDSIDE?
N
G TO USE THE
ESONT, YOU H
THAT DOE'TM LIKELY I
POLITICIZED. ESPECIALLY WHENTHI
LOT OF JUSTRTMENT PEOPLE WOULK
ISSUE  YM NOT HEREFEND THEMEI D
CRITICISIS FAIY
REPUBLICAN IN NG.YOU'VE BEEN WIO
CRITICIZTHEM.N MARJORIEON YOUR
AFTER TH.DES CHARGED SYLVANIA MT
.T
THERE'S REPUBLICANCONTACT, CARP
GENERAL MERRICK GARLAND SHOULD
BE
THAT RC,E,YOU.
D IT US SEEM LEXTREMIST DE MJOAY
LINS NOT ON
THAT WSPARENCY THE MS WE'RE L
IT'S NOT THOSEATDOJ FULLRRANTE
LEADY PARTNEATTACKING AN FBI --
>> N SAYINATLL T'S COMPLETELY W.
BUT THAT'S WHERE 99% OF
LAST TCHECKED,AD USU NDF CRITICS
FRONOF JUTS', YE OUT PROTN
EN
ANAUGT
THQUITE A BIT OF
REPUICHEN WE
I LIKEO  ODE, IT'S L BAD NOO IS
>> ANO QUESTION, ALL
R OFEGS BUSS
MENTED M
O NEW YORK C
THERN RESEARCHSYRACUS THESMIGRA
THE GRILL BE ALLOWED TO  IY E D
IMMIGRATI J
T
WHAT DO YOU CALL THI  ME, IT, B?
>> HE'THERE'S NO SECRET.MOVE.
PAY ATTENTION TDESPERIO
WHAT WE'RE DNG
ICH IS WHY IN THSICALLY EVERYON
BORDER HAS THEHOOD.
PREHENSIONS JU THIS YEAR.
THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER.
ENNEW YORK ANDGOING TO
, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A FEW THOUSAND
TIONND HIGHLUSE SOMESOLVE THIS .
IT'S INFRINGEMENT ON RULE OF
LAW.R AND IMMOL TO
MILLIONS UPO
LAW-ABIDING IMMIGRANTS
SEO CHANCE OF INM BECAUSE
BECAUSE THEY'RE
GEOGRAPH TO THN
IT'SOT.  TALK ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
YEAR Y
AWAL
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HASE S
INTELLIGENCES UNDEDEHAT
RECONSTITUTED.
THNISTRATION WNG
LIGENCE
PARTNERS WERE AB O
AL ZAWAHIRI.
T IS DT RR THDRAW
DOESN'T LOOK BAD GIVEN THE FACT
WAS TAKEN OUT.ENU TALK
GETRUS JUST ON THE
TKI W -- IT'EAAT REALLY HA
W.
THE OTHER THING CLEAR FROM THE H
ORRATHATT WHATUTS THN HARB
TH
G
AS PART OF THE REASON WEEV TEREE
MADE. TO AEAL THATAT
SO, YOU KNOW,  FRUSTRATES ME
OUANTA
SPEADIDN'T LEARN ANY
T 20 YEARS.
OUR POLITICIANS AND OUR LEADS
E H ABOUT N PEOPLE
WHAT'SPE
IT'S NOT THIS NORMAL WAR WHERE U
SIGN A
TH N EVER WA
ATTACKED ANTHER
OUGO
OUPOO SEIT FROM HAPPENAGAIN.
EVER HAPPENING A
RESRCURCES,
SORT OF FIGUREDOUT THAT RIGHT .
WE HADN'T LOST A OVER YEAR
JUM AD VPS ANDE D STRATEGIC BAGR
CLOSE TO CLOO CHINA.
UP.ONALO BRING THE
TROOPS HOME.D OF A
HAT NATION